if you died and found yourself trapped
in a terrifying alien death gate what
would you do the fate of the world rests
in your hands and everything in this
city is out to brutally tear you apart
I'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the gantt's death games in gants oh this
guy Kato here is on his way home to
surprise his little brother with a
birthday cake out of nowhere he sees
crowds of people sprinting towards him
trying to get away from this old man
crawling on the floor covered in blood
he decides to run over and help the man
out but that's when he notices a masked
man approaching him with a knife okay
one second I'm off getting a cake from
my little brother the next thing I'm
being attacked by a psycho with a knife
what Japan's Next Top Model Kato did
here is more dumb than Dom trying to buy
a dive watch When Alan I know that Dom
can't even swim rushing in first thing
is the worst thing that you could do
what I would do is first assess the
situation keeping my distance I'll walk
to the left side and right side with a
subway platform I'm not going to walk
over there to get stabbed by a psycho
who could easily be hiding behind this
divider which he was hiding behind after
making sure I think the coast is clear
then and only then will I walk over to
see if the old guy is dead or not if
he's dead great I can move on with my
day if not then we'll decide if we'll be
a good guy and help him out but Kato
didn't do this and now we're stuck
trying to save ourselves all for trying
to be the hero now that I have this guy
coming towards me we have to move
quickly I'm immediately going to back
away and gain some distance if I have a
clear line of sight to the stairs up and
out of the subway I'm taking it and
getting out of Dodge if I don't then I'm
going to again keep my distance and
quickly back away from the psycho with a
knife and flip around my backpack to the
front and on my chest putting my arms
through the straps all the stuff that is
in my backpack is going to slow down the
knife and hopefully protect my vital
organs this killer coming to attack me
now attacked that old dude in broad
daylight and clearly didn't care about
any of the cameras that I'm sure are
scattered around all over the place and
it's likely that we won't be able to
talk this guy out of it if we can't run
away we're going to have to defend
ourselves by putting our backpack in
front of us and using our little
brother's gift as a weapon for
self-defense sorry little brother I'm
sure he'll get over it once I tell him I
used his cake to save my life unable to
defend himself the masked killer quickly
overpowers Kato and violently stabs him
to death but just then he wakes back up
in An Empty Apartment room with no
memory of how he got there but this
isn't hello it's so much worse Kato
notices a strange black sphere across
the room and he meets other people just
to like him he finds out that everyone
here also died in various ways before
being brought back to life and ended up
in this room with no explanation given
no explanation except one this old man
tells him that everyone here has been
forced to participate in Endless death
games fighting for their lives until
they manage to free themselves from this
responsibility or die try Kato thinks
this is awesome sick joke but has no
idea just how dangerous this game he's
just entered is out of nowhere a scary
children's song begins playing from the
black sphere playing a message for
everyone on the screen the black sphere
declares that everyone's old lives have
now ended and that it will decide how to
use their new lives and it gives
everyone their next kill Target they
must must complete their mission before
their time Runs Out Tattoo is too
horrified to think just as he discovers
that the mysterious fear is called gants
and they reveal to him something
horrifying they tell him that Japan has
recently been invaded by aliens from an
unknown origin and people like Kato on
the verge of death have been tasked with
stopping these aliens no matter what it
takes in countless death games they
cannot Escape they cannot run they can
only fight gants then opens up and
displays their weapons and their combat
ready body armor but sunglasses guy here
has had enough of this BDSM bullcrap and
tries to leave the locked room but
that's when this guy puts a big fatty
right through his gray matter blowing
him up and terrifying the rest of the
group okay one second ago Carter was off
getting a birthday cake for his little
brother and then died and is now somehow
in a horrifying Twisted death King and
his teammates like this kid here just
showed us that not only does he think
that he's the top dog of this group and
clearly doesn't give two shits about
keeping any of us alive what I would do
if I was caught it would be to First
assess the area they are in and see if
we are truly trapped inside this
apartment because if that is the case
that makes the people that I'm stuck
with in this room all the more important
arming ourselves is obvious but we'll do
little in the long run if Kato here
doesn't try to improve the team's
Dynamics what this kid did to sunglasses
guy and the reaction that old man in
this girl gave in response to that
terrifying incident makes it clear that
this group doesn't share any factors
that would contribute to Good Team
Dynamics which if we assessed everybody
as a group right now none of them are
demonstrating the five variables that
would contribute to a more effective
group dynamic to survive right now
tattoo needs to be ruthless and this
means they unlike this kid Kato needs to
know when to control his emotions and
this means playing nice with everyone by
bringing this group together since this
this is a death game establishing a
compelling direction to drive the team
towards like focusing on hunting down
their target objectives helping to
motivate everyone here to focus on the
goal in order to win the game because
while I won't risk my life for these
strangers when the time comes creating a
sense of team spirit within the group
will help me to survive in the long run
and will be the most important thing
Kato here should do if he wants to
escape this nightmare alive this
murderer freak introduces himself as
Nishi but we'll call him creepy face and
everyone tells him that they don't have
time to mess around old man and lady
hair products tell Kato to quickly put
on his body suit armor as the show is
about to begin everyone begins
teleporting to their next death game
location arriving at their new Arena the
gang becomes shocked when they realize
that they've just been transported to
Osaka different from all their previous
death games set in Tokyo and they're
terrified as hell out of nowhere they
get an alert on their digital map that
something horrifying is headed their way
readying their guts they see something
sinister approaching Kato begins
Sweating Bullets as these two log on to
their incoming Target but fail to make a
direct hit okay this is horrible not
only can we be brought back from the
dead but now we're taking orders from
this magic 8 ball that has the power to
manipulate time and space and these two
old man and lady hair products are
useless when it comes to actual combat
with the exception of creepy Nishi over
here but he's batshit crazy anyways
which means we can't rely on him to do
anything that he doesn't want to do
while I would love to run away I know
that's a mistake because with the level
of technology that Gantz has I wouldn't
be surprised if these suits have
built-in trackers which means any
attemptively would be pointless and
would probably get me killed the only
one on our group that looks competent
and knows what they're doing is creepy
face Nishi over here I would make nice
with this guy as soon as possible but
through respect and admiration and not
by ass kissing because if that happens
he might end up like Channing Tatum that
one time when hell froze over since we
can't run away I would two birds one
stone this situation by sticking with
this group but also establish a
hierarchy within the group this
terrifying alien that came running
towards us is the exact reason why Kato
should order his group to get to high
ground for a better vantage point over
the area and to gain some distance from
any stragglers that could pop up near us
since we are currently located in a
classic narrow Japanese Street which
means we gotta get out of here as soon
as possible if we look closely there is
an open garage door located here right
when the gang first teleported in which
seems to be an automatic garage door as
well now in the event of an emergency
within the city on the off chance
certain areas of the city would not have
power it's known that most garage doors
have a manual release to control the
door and to open and close it which
means we'll be able to do it ourselves
in the event there is no power to it
we'll be able to withstand whatever
attacks this Abomination throws at it
doing this we will be able to then kill
the creature and also stay safe and plan
our next move Nishi saves everyone and
kills this alien right in front of Kato
freaking out he demands that someone
tell him what's really going on an old
man fills him in on the official rules
of gats they must survive and kill all
the aliens before the timer runs out but
if they die in game they'll be dead for
real that's when they get alerted that
horde of alien monsters are headed right
for them getting spotted they run for
their lives but Nishi and old men
quickly get pinned down as Kato tries to
help them firing his weapon he realizes
in horror he can't kill it and gets
crushed by the giant monster head but he
finds out that his bodysuit armor can
handle more than he thought the group
gets surrounded and prepares to die just
as they get saved by another group of
gants players they are the Osaka team
veteran players and among the best in
the game they quickly make fun of Kato's
team's suckiness as weaklings and Kato's
group is forced to watch as the Osaka
studs kick ass and take names wiping out
this entire alien horde in a matter of
minutes while this team is incredibly
skilled they are also very cocky old man
then informs Kato of something that will
soon change his life and tells him that
if you score 100 points in Gans you get
access to one out of three amazing
rewards one unlock bed weapons 2
resurrected dead teammate or three have
your memory wiped and become free from
this alien death game okay this is new
information and great news we now have a
way to get out of this hell Kato here
has just discovered new members of gants
and ones that are much better than
Kato's group these Osaka studs are
basically Adrenaline Junkies and
megalomaniacs married to the game and
chose not to leave and that means that
our problems just got a whole lot easier
if Kato places cards right we know by
now that his team is useless old man and
lady hair products Reika over here while
sweets are better used as meat Shields
than they are against players they
played this game before and yet somehow
they still don't realize that their guns
have crap range and creepy face Nishi
while good as a player is batshit crazy
more sour looking than a chunky grumpy
cat kantu is better off connecting with
Tim Osaka for now it's clear that they
think his team is pathetic which means
if I was him I would keep my mouth shut
and let these try hard wannabes do what
they want to do and show off I want to
survive and I'm more than happy to ask
to join their team and be at the bottom
of the totem pole for now but I would do
this with a purpose in Mind by letting
them take over we'll be able to let them
rack up kills and do some of the heavy
lifting for us while we could try to
rack up the easier targets collecting up
points in the process it would also
benefit Kato if he tried to get on the
good side of this bald batty head honcho
over here as he could provide us with
more information about this game while
still racking up easier kills and
gaining points and even maybe allow us
to swipe any loot that these more
experienced players happen to drop
should they get injured or killed
because gaining points at her weaponry
and surviving and getting overall
stronger in this game is the only way
out of this KATU is shocked at what old
man tells him about the game he mentions
that sent the Osaka team is now here
they can just wait out this round of the
game and leave the killing to the
professionals creepy face Nishi ignores
this and leaves the group to go find the
final boss of this level worth 100
points but he has no idea just how hard
that will be to accomplish Kato then
notices some innocent civilians getting
hunted down by more alien monsters old
man tells him that they should ignore
them and focus on Surviving makato's
hero attitude disagrees with him and he
declares that while he is alive he'll
try to save as many innocent people as
he can old man then gives Kato some
coins and tells him to go call his
family in case something happens to him
Kato then Parts ways with the old man
not realizing that a mysterious woman is
spying on him Kato reaches a payphone
booth and calls his little brother
making up some excuse about where he's
been and tells him that he'll be home
soon but then he sees some innocent
people get terrorized by this monster
Kato quickly rushes over to help them
but just as quickly gets disarmed by the
terrifying monster he tries his best to
outsmart the alien and barely manages to
get away with his life the mysterious
girl then approaches Kato and introduces
herself as anzu she tells him that she's
been watching him and warns him that
playing the hero card will soon get him
killed but Kato refuses to listen
fascinated by his good heart she guides
him to another group of Trapped people
nearby and they stumble across this
horrifying monster okay I just learned
three very important things one we can
get out of here too my team sucks and
three it's clear that Kato has the most
pure heart and is more adorable than a
Scottish Fold on the internet and this
means that this guy will likely not stop
being a good person until the day he
dies or somehow defeats the game oh I
love this guy but he's stupid and given
how stupid he is the first option is
more likely again he decided to risk his
life for some more old people which
makes total sense but given his
determination and stubbornness taking
down this monster seems to be the move
here after all he does need more gas
points if he wants to have any shot of
escaping this hell hole but before he
goes in like a regular white knight
unlike before he needs to take to
account what he's actually up against
the thing this idiot is looking to take
on looks like the super-sized version of
a gorilla with a sword at the end of its
tail and it is not focused on us I'm
taking anzu with me and we're going to
run down on the opposite side of the
street and get as close as we can to the
monster then once we're in position
we're going to run up alongside it and
as soon as I see its neck I'm going to
unload my clip into the thing once it
turns its face I'm having on to fire her
shot and we're going to Sprint away like
hell freaky freaky King Kong over there
has no idea that me and ansu are even
watching it which means we should
utilize this opportunity to its fullest
now does that put the old people in
danger yes absolutely but if they're
going to survive they're going to
survive according to my timeline I'm not
going to rush my plan to die for them
Kato shocks ansu by running into battle
this terrifying alien without a second
thought stunned by his good boy acting
terrified she abandons him in
frustration leaving KATU to fight this
thing solo sliding in he tries to
distract the monster but quickly gets
his weapon destroyed shocked and now
he desperately tries to think of what to
do just as ansu returns at the last
minute saving him she gets the monster's
attention and Kato uses this moment to
spear its eye and quickly retrieves
anzu's dropped weapon killing the alien
once and for all and saving the day he
rushes over to see if anzu is all right
and she quickly Falls for him hashtag
classic anime style the two then
obviously agree to work together and try
to save as many innocent people as they
can meanwhile Reika and old man tried to
survive the night when they come across
a terrifying battle between two giants
KATU and ansu finally catch up with it
but then they get surrounded by the
military injuring old man they demand to
know who they are but out of nowhere a
hideous monster runs into them and rips
the flesh out of the entire military
unit anzu and Kato quickly worked
together to take it out but this demon
is tough as hell and quickly manages to
break free just as the Osaka studs show
up to try to save the day this guy
starts crushing the Beast with a gravity
gun but quickly realizes that this is
not like the rest of the aliens they've
killed it somehow doesn't die and gets a
hold of him as the man starts begging
his friend to help him out but Captain
oblivious over there thinks everything
is fine Baldi headman honcho uses the
gun in his hand and desperately fires
off rounds into the thing's face
everyone thinks the battle is won but
the man then realizes that everything is
not fine and that his friend is dead out
of nowhere they see a creature slowly
and calmly walk towards him the
remaining Osaka stud tries to attack him
but it Dodges every attack with these he
tries to grab the alien but that's when
things begin to get a little bit naughty
and it shapeshifts into a rather
questionable anime character and it
swallows him whole okay this is insane
Kato's team right now has just come
across the boss that Gantz put on their
kill list this is narakion worth 100
points killing this thing means that
anyone here instantly unlocks the best
rewards in the game as soon as it's over
but we all know it's not going to be
that easy this creature as we've seen
has the power to transform rapidly
capable of turning into crazy things and
beastly forms its shape-shifting ability
also means that this thing has the
ability to regenerate however there's
one thing that makes me suspect that
based on what we saw of this alien that
we may be able to defeat it it's noted
that the samurai Osaka stud gave
everything he got to try and kill this
alien yet couldn't it's almost as if
this alien predicted his moves from
before he even made them or was able to
see them in slow motion hear me up now
because this Monster's reflexes are
similar in speed and efficiency to that
of a housefly which is a pesky little
bug that has no problems avoiding
getting swatted and the reason why
they're so efficient at this is due to
their Superior Vision they have up to 6
000 mini lenses on each eye flies have
some of the fastest Vision on Earth and
can literally see a hand coming at them
in slow motion just like this guy which
means attacking this thing up close and
personal is not the thing to do I'm
pretty certain that ranged attacks would
work better if I was in charge I would
set up our best Sharpshooters here to
set up a hide side somewhere way back
this creature doesn't seem to be as
aggressive as of now and its move in
Pace is rather slow and obvious this
means that once our people are in place
I'm going to use one or two of Kato's
team members to lure the creature into
our Killzone our snipers will have a
clear shot of taking this thing out a
long range attack is our best bet in
being able to kill this thing while we
don't know for sure if this will work
this our best bet as of now and trying
to take this thing out winning 100
points and finally getting out of Dodge
Kato mans up and fires round after round
but it's new use his teammates join in
on the fight but they are royally
screwed and Kato gets caught and is
about to die when he gets saved by
creepy Nishi hiding in plain sight
everyone here thinks the worst is over
but the horrors have only just begun
suddenly a new creature rises from the
pool of blood one that no one has ever
seen before Standing Tall over these
mortals it critically enters creepy
Nishi in seconds and forces everyone to
run coming across the two same Giants
from earlier the battle continues and
then they all see the game's greatest
player step out of his giant Mecha suit
killing the giant Minotaur alien once
and for all Oka the veteran player and
the best within the game and he makes
his way over to the monster that killed
Tim Osaka Kato and his crew watch as the
two battle it out Oka uses all of his
skills Tech and weaponry and finally
beats this thing down or so he thinks to
his surprise another creature rises from
the smoke more devastating than anything
anyone has ever seen before Oka knows
this one is different he tries to attack
it but it regenerates in seconds and
quickly overpowers him almost killing
him but suddenly Oka abandons his suit
coming up from behind slicing this
monster in half Kato thinks it's over
but while walking away Oka tells him
that this creature will soon come back
and that he doesn't have the Firepower
right now to kill it so he leaves the
group to go and resupply but dumber than
a box of rocks Kato thinks that he can
finish the job here and now and he walks
over to kill it suddenly an explosive
device bursts up into the air and old
man quickly saves Kato everyone is
forced to watch the final transformation
of this monster this horrifying skeleton
looking thing they cower in fear and
Kato tries to attack it but easily gets
knocked back his suit finally breaks and
he lays helpless in front of this alien
and it asks him where is the other one
he was fun to play with and it tells him
that it'll come back for him and it
flies off the girls approach Kato and
quickly tell him that they all need to
run picado somehow convinces them that
they must stop this thing win the game
and finally make it back to his kid
brother no matter what it takes and he
convinces them to help him come up with
a plan to kill this thing okay this is
suicide you want to go die go right
ahead I gotta get back home man no way
am I going to try to fight what the
strongest player couldn't kill if memory
serves me right the rules of the game
are if you can stay alive by the time
the timer runs out regardless of injury
and how bad you're hurt you will recover
hachiro Oka won the game seven times
which means this thing can be killed but
the odds of us pulling this off are
astronomically low this is so insane the
monster they just met is the same one
the boss of this round and now he
shape-shifted into the most terrifying
creature they've ever seen this thing is
not only dangerous as hell I'm done
letting the lovable idiot Kato tell us
what we should do I'm taking over now
this is what we're going to do last we
checked these guys had about an hour
left on the gants clock and now surely
they have less than 20 minutes until the
game ends which means they only need to
stay alive for 20 more minutes now while
retreating does seem like a cop-out move
doing so in this situation would in
actuality be their best bet since this
creature isn't after us for now and now
we're so close to ending the game and
what we've seen from the invaluable
moment of watching Oka and rachio on
fight we can now say with almost
absolute loot certainty the only way to
take this thing out is by long-range
attacks both the Osaka studs and Oka try
to attack this thing head on and failed
once the timer runs out and we get back
to gants I'm going to immediately start
investing in whatever points that we
have earned into getting better gear and
weapons and particularly making sure
that we get better long range Weaponry
in preparation for the next round of the
game in order to come back better
prepared against this alien who will
surely be still around terrorizing the
city Kato's team prepares a Kill Zone
just as the monster shows back up now
holding the head of the game's former
greatest player horrified with no
position just yet this monster marks
Kato for debt and the girls quickly try
to snipe it from a distance they quickly
take pot shots and soon overwhelm the
creature panicking it begins blasting
beams of energy everywhere and Kato
tries to surprise attack it but gets
blown back Ansel reacts to this in
horror and yells out to her Crush giving
away her position and the alien Fires at
her barely clinging onto the building
Reika tries to continue firing and Kato
tries to get to his weapon but then he
gets spotted the monster pairs to kill
him right here and now but anzu out of
nowhere sacrifices her life as she gets
brutally sliced in half in front of Kato
creepy Nishi then rides up and crashes
his vehicle at the monster giving KATU
enough time to take the final Kill Shot
destroying the boss once for all and
ending the game with his legs blown off
Kato Embraces his forced upon short-term
girlfriend holding her corpse and
everyone gets beamed back into the
gant's room now regenerated and good as
new everyone looks to Gantz as it
finally scores everyone's points Reika 6
points old man two-point creepy face 12
points and Kato 100 points everyone is
shocked and Gans offers Kato three
options that he can pick as his reward
1. new weapons two the resurrection of a
dead player three Freedom at the cost of
having his memory wiped so Kato thinks
about his little brother and decides to
make the hardest decision that he's ever
had to make and the rest of the crew
thanks him for his service except Nishi
but we don't really care about him happy
Kato bids these two farewell and tells
them that he'll see them at the next
death game not realizing that by the way
he's played this game before and had
already long ago fought with all of them
before in countless death games he
willingly chose to have his memory wiped
they all chose to keep their mouth shut
because if they had told him then he
would have never left he would have kept
trying to play the gants games until he
revived every single one of his still
dead former teammates so they decided to
be nice and spare him from knowing that
making playing against the ultimate
excuse for wannabe deadbeat family
members
don't want to be no deadbeat dad then
like comment let us know what you liked
and of course didn't like it don't
forget to check out the how to be
playlist down below